how hard is it to say I don't care if
Freddie and Fanny is buying our paper I
don't think this is sustainable long
term and we got to get away from it how
hard in that moment is it to do that
you're in someone's question I'm asking
right because you're like okay who is
who is safer than Freddie and Fanny I
was in the military when you get out of
the military what did they say you know
you can buy zero financing if you're a
vet right you have this loan that you
can go okay
Freddie Fanny hey Freddy Fanny I work at
Freddy I work at Fannie Hall fan Freddy
and Fanny are going bankrupt what
Freddie and Fanny are going how is that
even possible so how hard is it to know
that Freddie and Fanny or others are
buying the paper for you to say I'm
still not going to sell this paper
because I don't think this makes sense
long-term for the company
I totally agree with that and uh again
no other major institution cut their
lending 74 percent three years leading
up up to before the financial crisis
nobody sold off as many of their loans
to try to prepare it I thought the
housing market was very vulnerable we
tried to do what we could uh and we cut
our market share think about nationally
we cut our market share in half
and very difficult running a business a
large business National and to know that
you're going to not be funding loans to
know that you're not going to provide
employment opportunity you're going to
cut back 74 percent we laid off 15 000
people out of the mortgage area over
that period what was that period give us
some like month to month well this was
2003 to 2007 we actually cut our lending
by 74 you laid off 15 from 2003 to 2007.
and that's where the 15 000 jobs went in
that same window how much did that two
how much did that 15 000 layoffs was in
07 what percentage of it was an 07. I
don't have the numbers in front of me it
clearly accelerated as as we just kept
getting out of more and more of the
businesses you got out of the riskier
part of wholesale lending and those
things and it was a it was a
continuation uh process but what do you
think about the way Angelo's how
different did mozillo like what was
their business model how different were
they than you Countrywide
I think the major difference is again
Countrywide was originating all for sale
to Fannie Freddie and Wall Street and I
think their attitude was much more about
if somebody will buy the product we're
going to originate it and they they
increased their market share
considerably
um over those four-year periods while we
cut ours in half in fact if you go back
to 2003 uh Wells Fargo Washington Mutual
and Countrywide all had about the same
market shares they were the leaders in
the country and those guys kind of kept
growing and we just shrunk ours away I
got criticized badly by Wall Street we
lost tons of people to Countrywide
because they wanted to ramp up and we
were trying to pull back again 74
percent in hindsight wasn't enough I
guess but that's a pretty major uh
business call how did you feel about it
during that time saying 05 who was who
was Angelo mazzillo to you in 05 not
today in o5
I'll take it before in in 2003 I viewed
him as a first of all I knew him very
well and it was a probably our fiercest
competitor in the mortgage space and I
think the guy was very knowledgeable
very deep and you know a very committed
for it and a fierce competitor uh I
think as time went on I became more and
more concerned that they were going down
that attitude of selling a broader and
broader product line as long as somebody
would buy the product and
um and since you know we just kind of
just became less comfortable with with
many of those products and and what was
happening in real estate and kind of
went the other way when you say someone
would buy the product you're not talking
about the consumer am I correct you're
talking about the securitization that's
right so that that Angela was basically
just selling the stock into Wall Street
and he could keep his foot on the
accelerator longer you had a charter and
so that's that's the point you're making
am I right yeah the major again we tried
to not just take the attitude if we that
if somebody would buy it from us that we
buy it you know for securitization that
we would originate and sell it to and we
kind of said uh these are getting
riskier riskier we got to be careful
we're probably going to hold a lot of
these products in portfolio particularly
the adjustable rate ones and we just
took a more a different a more
conservative point of view and um and
again I think our view was correct but
in in hindsight again nobody including
ourselves anticipated a 40 reduction in
housing prices and I thought a uh I
thought a correction of 10 to 20 percent
was appropriate and very likely uh I did
not anticipate that the FED would in my
opinion screw up so much to cause a full
Panic to cause what turned out to be a
40 decrease in housing prices so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]